bonsoir je vous propose aujourd'hui de
partir à la découverte du château de
recours aurait course est un petit
village de 25 habitants située au plein
milieu de la haute saône à sept
kilomètres de villersexel érigé au 12e
siècle
il a fallu attendre 2 20e pour que le
château deviennent propriété d'un
roturier
[Musique]
faut-il appeler château le site de riz
cours il s'agit en fait une maison forte
à côté de laquelle se trouvait une
grande ferme
de plus peu de seniors ont vraiment
demeurer tout au plus se contente-t-il
de passer récit pour prélever les taxes
et impôts en urgence peu de bataille de
sièges et autres péripéties historiques
du monde pour ce que les amoureux du
hawk l'année dans les archives
l'histoire est au calme de recours a
laissé un site par un état aux
générations suivantes le corps et pour
ce prix vous rassemblement dans la
seconde moitié du xix ème siècle se
composait de coeur
deux couples une cour d'habitations ici
ce rempart autour d'une cour de ferme
l'ensemble de t d
une fois sont à moins que de thon jaune
parce que plus importante que les autres
et c'est le réflexe de cours si dans
tous les bâtiments d'habitation ont été
reconstruits à partir de la renaissance
comme le bâtiment derrière nos airs
complétée au 18e sont les trois grandes
époques de construction
la marche à la loi ont été vendus en
même temps l'actuel propriétaire succès
nous aligner deux doubles connu comme
nicolas rolin chancelier bourgogne au
xvème siècle
france télé
s'ils étaient sensibilisés à travers les
toutes les personnes qui se sont
intéressés à ce lieu l'ont visitée ça
fait quoi des propriétaires de châteaux
du moyen-âge à beaucoup d'occupations
beaucoup de préoccupations et c'est le
rêve de toute une toute une enfance ça
vous apporte des joies d'être
propriétaire a bien sûr heureusement
beaucoup beaucoup de joie ne serait-ce
que de le faire visiter de voir que
beaucoup de gens s'intéressent à ce lieu
ça c'est ça c'est déjà des jours
jean-pierre qu'on l'espère habituelle
elle redescend
le temps n'a pas beaucoup d'importance
qu attend quand même important du
patrimoine local et il mérite qu'on s'y
attache et qu'on le conte l'empêchent de
s'abîmer plus est ce que vous avez déjà
chiffrer l'argent que vous avez mis dans
ce château
non jamais jamais jamais exactement mais
peut-être un million de francs jusqu'à
maintenant quand vous avez commencé
cette restauration est ce que vous
pensiez y passer autant de temps autant
d'argent
about en deux temps oui bien sûr je sais
pas si je le verrai un jour restaurer et
le but n'est pas vraiment de restaurer
en fait le but et deux aides de le
conserver au moins dans l'état où il est
et ça vous embête pas de pas voir le
château termine non donc est ce que
j'aurai à faire après
[Musique]